المشجعين الى اني نفاق دينا وفزع مفجوعين
طابور من الجائعين المتلهفين لمعرفه
مصيرهم احتضنت الخيام الجميع باستثناء
محمد واولاده سيبيتون بالعراء اليوم بسبب
نقص الخيام ما حصلنا خيمه لانه الزلزال
ضرب 10 ولايات عشر ولايات يعني عدد ليس
بالقليل كلايه بتطلع مليونين نسمه مليون
نسمه يعني اكبر دوله ما بتستطيع تغطي بين
مساعدات الانقاذ او المساعدات الانسانيه
والحمد لله يعني الحكومه التركيه ما قصرت
يلهو الاطفال على امل ان ينسوا ازمه ستؤثر
عليهم مستقبلا كما يقول مختصون احمد اخرج
قريبه وزوجته من تحت الانقاب لم يلحق على
ابنهما الذي فارق الحياه يعيش في هذه
الخيمه 13 فردا من عائلته والله نحن كنا
نايمين انا ومرتين حسينا بزنزال يعني بس
نحن فكرنا بنومنا يعني بنام
بدا الزلزال هنا زلزل البشر والحجر قبل ان
يتركهم في العراء خارج منازلهم يسكنون
الخيام ويتلقون المساعدات من جهات محليه
ودوليه
لاجل غير معلوم عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
قهرمان مرعش